[Music]
hey I thought that was you come on in
here welcome to the uplift we have a
great show for you today and a great
cast of characters including these a
couple who says Russell Crowe helped
their small business in a big way what
did he do to help their bookstore well
stick around we'll tell you and a man
who was taking a leisurely fight that
turned into a life-saving rescue mission
when he spotted a woman in danger
a group of neighbors who worked together
to help a blind woman in their Community
what they did to give her a big Boost
Plus a man who has run
170 marathons and there is a good reason
behind them all in the Childhood cancer
survivor who is now in college and
giving back to kids just like him well
all of that plus our heartwarming videos
that you just need to see you are
watching The Uplift
[Music]
welcome to the show that lifts you up
well at least for the next 30 minutes of
your day I'm Nate Burleson and we are
going to start with a little bookstore
in the UK that recently got a big Boost
from an A-list actor here's Caitlin
O'Kane with the story
once upon I'm in the queen
Orange and a cozy Bookshop opened just
months before the pandemic struck the
owners Dan and Leanne Frid started
crowdfunding to save their beloved
Bookshop and when they discovered a five
thousand dollar donation they were
shocked by what they saw
instead we checked the name and I sort
of was like
Russell Ira Crow and Dan went Russell
throat I went no call me Russell's bro
and then we did a bit of digging and we
were like it is Russell bird this is
absolutely insane that's right that
Russell Crowe are you not entertained
from that moment on people far beyond
Norwich were entertained and started
following their story asking us about it
in the shop was much busier because
people wanted to come in and say hello
and and the Press were interested and we
were on Australian Breakfast Television
which was insane it feels like a huge
weight has been lifted it's completely
transformed not just the crowdfunder the
money is is lovely but it's the way
people have responded to coming in the
shop they may never know why Crow chose
their Bookshop but perhaps it's because
Dan and Leanne do so much for Norwich we
run um something called Dorothy angry
reader Awards where we gift 50 pounds
worth of boots to children who don't
have book money whose parents working
incredibly hard but they just don't have
spare money for books and things like
that so we asked for nominations from
schools and they recommend some children
who they think would benefit and we have
a huge celebration evening here and we
gift books to the children last year
they gave away books to 30 kids in need
with a donation 50 kids will be chosen
this year they're also using the money
to build a wheelchair ramp to make their
shop accessible to everyone
Dan Leanne and their Bookshop are always
there for their Community because their
Community was always there for them
someone took a chance on us that we are
from very working class four backgrounds
we were certainly not able to have
access to books to own necessarily as
much as we wanted to as children and
people took the chance on us when we
were kids they believed in us they they
saw the potential of us and we get to
pay that forward through the shop if Mr
Crow ever wants to come peruse the
shelves Leanne and Dan are ready for him
he is a gold loyalty five customer of
the shop now so he gets 10 off for life
should he ever wander in
[Music]
sometimes it's about helping other
people write their next chapter okay we
now introduce you to a doctor who has
made running marathons his thing not
just for his own health benefits but to
help others as well here's James
Crawford
weekend Dr Glenn Gail Hood will run his
45th Marine Corps Marathon he's only
missed it twice but he's up for almost
any race so how many marathons have you
run 170 to date and Counting how many
continents seven continents he saves his
medals but his true passion is saving
lives with his non-profit mission to
heal it brings medical supplies and
training to the most remote corners of
the world we have done what we can to
help not just to heal the folk that we
see immediately by cutting and sewing
but by teaching those skills such that
it continues Beyond us his medical
missions are inspired by his runs the
marathon is a good metaphor because it
takes discipline it takes effort and it
takes a commitment that's what health
care is Dr Gail hood is 80 years old so
how much longer do you plan to keep
doing missions and running marathons
until the next one and the next one and
the one after that because crossing a
Finish Line means it's time to start a
new Mission Jan Crawford CBS News
durwood Maryland
and here I am trying to find motivation
to run marathons and he's got it figured
out okay a group of neighbors came
together to fix up a house for a blind
woman in their community and they also
restored her faith in others here's CBS
Sacramento's Marley Ginter with the
story
[Music]
from the front yard
to the back this community's got it
covered I've just been stunned I I
it's like all of a sudden I've got a
whole family here blind from the time
she was a baby Faye Abbas didn't realize
how run down her home of 30 plus years
had become
that's when her neighbor Paul Bridge
rounded up the community to fix it up
for free and so we all kind of did the
old uh what do you call this we all
break hands together
and the deal was sealed it renews My
Hope because these last two years there
was a lot of Separation a lot of
divisiveness not only in our country but
in our neighborhood we just didn't know
each other they know each other now
weeks working side by side and everyone
here is volunteering I feel blessed to
live in a community where we can put all
of our differences aside and help our
fellow fellow neighbor I am the one
who's blessed by what they're doing
then they they are the story
dang it sorry I didn't cry it's okay you
can tell the workout here is immense
from all of the painting the sanding
replacing the paneling all of the siding
but that's not all they will be adding a
personal touch they asked if her doors
could be painted pink I'm thrilled about
those pink doors I really like pink I
can't see it but I like the feel of it
colors have feel Faye doesn't need to
see all the work there's no doubt she
can feel it this is beyond anything I
would ever ever have imagined ever
I am so thankful
colors
I can feel let that sink in for a little
bit all right coming up meet the realtor
who was in the right place at the right
time and save the woman stuck in a canal
plus the college student who overcame
cancer as a child and now he's able to
help other kids in his position
and of course our heartwarming videos
you just need to see stick around we
will be right back
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the uplift we now have
the heartwarming videos that you just
need to see starting with this one
you are looking at Mrs duckwall a
cafeteria worker at namesman Parkway
Elementary School in Virginia she also
happens to be hard of hearing so a
teacher at the school taught her
students how to sign to her at lunch
it's their way of making sure Mrs
duckwall feels included and now the
school is making it a goal for all
students to learn how to sign to it
that's what I'm talking about teaching
our kids how to make everyone feel
included
okay we're going to take you to another
school in Springboro Ohio
first grader Owen Moore wanted to honor
his favorite janitor for Halloween and
transform his wheelchair into the
sweeper he uses to clean the school
floors so a high school engineering
class got to work and built Owen's
costume then he got to surprise the
Beloved Janitor Mr Keith on Halloween
oh man
that's what I'm talking about
okay we have some more Halloween videos
for you and if you're looking for a
really really sweet video this one will
do the trick
the First shows a couple of kids in
Minnesota discovering a bold on the
porch that once had candy in it but was
now empty
yeah
except it's all gone
all right look at that see we think all
of these little
kids are just candy Grabbers but they're
not see some of these kids actually care
and they're giving back and it's good
for them too all that candy is bad for
your teeth all right now take a look at
Camden in Indiana
some people it took
a little fish
ah
can we put it together
I think that's enough candy Camden
see credit to these kids but you know
what I want to high-five their parents
because they learn that somewhere all
right you can watch more of our
heartwarming videos on Facebook that's
facebook.com
uplift news
coming up a group of kids honoring
someone important to them with a special
project
plus the man who suddenly found himself
making a daring rescue
how did he swoop in and save a woman's
Life we'll tell you in just a bit stick
around you're watching The Uplift
[Music]
the monarch butterfly was recently
declared endangered around the world but
there's a group of young people in
Maryland working to protect the
beautiful bugs here is Deborah alferon
with more
these students we are looking
[Music]
St Joan of Arc School in Aberdeen
Maryland there are milkweed are saving
the migratory monarch butterfly there's
also lavender this Garden is one of
about 3 000 certified Monarch way
stations at schools across the country
it grows milkweed which the monarch
caterpillar needs to live they are
pollinators so they help the
reproduction of flowers but the garden
might not be here if it weren't for two
forces of nature one is former principal
Tracy takarski she strived for her
students to be better than they even
thought they could be jakarski died
unexpectedly right before school started
last year it makes me feel pretty
awesome that she like she started this
and that we get to carry on her Legacy
what's so special about the monarch
butterfly it's about Charisma Chip
Taylor is that second Force the insect
ecologist founded Monarch watch at the
University of Kansas 30 years ago let's
see your shirt
plant milkweed inspiring schools to
plant these Gardens give it a little
push down and organizing the tagging of
the Butterflies to gather insight about
their yearly migration to Mexico if
we're losing monarch butterflies we're
losing other species
there's no question about that and
potentially losing lessons this Garden
can teach says new principal Diane
Kessler and we use it so so often to
teach the children so many things caring
for the Earth the life cycle after two
million butterflies tagged a million
milkweeds planted and 40 000 Garden
certified it's time for chip to spread
his wings why is it time to retire now
you're not 85 years old yet leaving the
fight to save Nature's icon of
conservation to the Next Generation oh
and look at that foreign
can we all agree butterflies are just so
so beautiful all right a realtor in
Florida was taking a leisurely flight
one Sunday morning when he spotted
someone in a canal and suddenly found
himself saving her life here CBS Miami's
Gabrielle arzola
for real Turk Cristiano this flight on a
paramotor is not just a hobby but he
uses it to get a bird's eye view of the
properties he's trying to sell
he says on Sunday mornings he normally
sees Wildlife at first he thought he saw
an alligator in this southwest
Miami-Dade Canal but when he got closer
so I flew closer to the car and I saw a
woman a woman screaming for help you can
see her floating and exhausted as she
holds on to her sunken car for dear life
I was the only person that could see
that situation Cristiano is an avid race
car driver skydiver and helicopter pilot
and he says it was tough for him to get
to her it was not an easy Landing and
you we had power lines cables we had
trees that generate rotors it's a
difficult Landing after some maneuvering
he was able to land he called over a
neighbor who was outside and asked to
get some rope and within minutes this
woman was finally able to get some rest
you can see the absolute relief on her
face the moment the neighbor pulls her
on to land Cristiano says God put him at
the right place at the right time I'm no
hero God is the true hero because he's
the one that put me on that situation at
that moment Miami-Dade fire rescue came
in shortly after but it's still unclear
how her car drove into this area this
Avid flyer has seen a lot through the
years but says this flight is by far the
most meaningful I always imagining
myself looking at my mother being
dragged out of the car of the water
he brought me to tears I mean
they say not all heroes wear caves but
you need to go get you a cape because
you are a hero indeed all right coming
up
a college student who survived Childhood
Cancer now he says his life has come
full circle you gotta stick around for
this you are watching The Uplift
[Music]
we now want to introduce you to a
Childhood cancer survivor who is in
college and says he's seen his life come
full circle here's Nancy Chen with the
story
Tucker Haas is on a full circle journey
and the path keeps leading him here to
State College Pennsylvania what does
Penn State mean to you Penn State saved
my life at the age of two Haas was
diagnosed with an aggressive form of
sarcoma in total I went through four
different stints with cancer twice
inside my face and twice in my right
lung I had two floor economy surgeries
77 radiation treatments hundreds of
chemotherapy treatments but his family
has no ever seen a medical bill and
that's because of a partnership between
Four Diamonds a Childhood Cancer
Research and support organization in
Thon the Penn State student-run
philanthropic effort known most notably
for its 46-hour dance Marathon
fundraiser
young and ambitious
on collects goes to children and their
families impacted by cancer
today as a nine-year-old Haas even
participated in the event in this viral
moment
[Music]
this will be your 20th on this year yeah
you've been going since you were really
little yeah it's just one of those
things when you walk into Thon that
you've never experienced it uh it's very
breathtaking seeing 15 plus thousand
students packed at the restaurant Center
on a snowy freezing cold weekend in
February and you just see all these kids
with the same passion the same love for
these children and families that are
going through cancer but the support
goes far or Beyond one night through
Thon a sorority and fraternity also
adopted Haas as one of their own what
would they do for you
I mean everything they would come visit
me at the hospital and drive two hours
on a weekend and spend the entire
weekend with me they would send me stuff
to the hospital toys and presents
looking back it really made an impact in
my life Haas has been cancer free for
almost 16 years when it came time to
apply for college he says Penn State was
a no-brainer
now a senior he's a leader in the very
same fraternity that looked after him as
a kid Alpha Tau Omega and he's giving
back to kids just like him
three-year-old Gus Baumgardner was
diagnosed with cancer at just two years
old Four Diamonds is paying for the now
three-year-old's treatment I don't know
how they do it because it's not even
like we get bills and we submit them we
don't get bills like at all Greta
Baumgardner is Gus's mom she credits a
support from Penn State and Haas himself
for helping carry their family through
this battle when you hear about Tucker's
story that not only did he successfully
beat Childhood Cancer but that he is
thriving like this what does that mean
to you it gave us some hope because
Tucker's Tucker had a hard hard journey
too and to see him many years later and
he's living a life that has purpose that
he is happy and content even with
everything he's gone through has given
us a lot of Hope do you see yourself in
these kids yeah
especially Gus if you probably put a
picture of the two of us side by side
two two-year-old little boys with bald
heads with so much energy the love of
life I'm here and now I'm able to
kind of get back to the families like us
it's neat to see it come full circle the
full circle moment in this story was
almost complete as Haas reflected on the
college students who looked after him
when he when he wore his own battle they
made a big difference in your life yeah
for sure
still people are still guys that I talk
to now but they now have children of
their own
um so that's that's crazy to see they
really did help change your life yeah
what would you say if I told you
they were standing behind you right now
we arranged a surprise visit with these
now men who were in their late teens and
early 20s when their fraternity first
adopted Haas you seen them grow up yeah
what has that been like crazy that's
insane I mean you think of him I think
of him as a three four five-year-old you
know I'm coming back to see this well
it's insane he calls you guys Role
Models but you guys also think of him as
a role model absolutely yes
source of strength for everybody yeah
when him and his family have done
sharing their story with uh countless
different pledge classes have come
through the fraternity to thawn itself I
mean he's an inspiration to all of us
Tucker was what brought us together Haas
graduates this spring with a sports
management degree he's not sure yet
where it'll take him but he hopes to
continue to inspire others what do you
want people to learn from you and your
story there's always a light at the end
of the tunnel I went through my journey
with cancer for a reason I'm at Penn
State for a reason it all just ties in
itself like why I'm here and why I have
the opportunity to do what I'm doing
that's an awesome story The Same Love
encouragement and strength that he
received from others as a child he is
passing it down to kids that are in need
so I challenge you do the same pass it
Forward today that's our show I hope
this news brightened up your day and you
know lifted you all the way up I'll see
you next time